को एक नमस्कार जर्मन से की हिंदी में के
वृक्ष एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज मैं
टेक्निकल्स में हम सीखने वाले हैं ऐसे
वर्क जो हमेशा लड़कियों के साथ आते हैं तो
आज हम यह क्यों सीखने वाला है कि 72
एपिसोड मुझे डॉक्टर के पास के लोगों ने
पूछा कि इस हेल्प अदृश्य क्यों नहीं यह
संपत्तिा की तो इसका आंसर आज हम देखेंगे
एक्चुअली अ आंसर दम इजी है क्योंकि हिंदी
में या अपनी सारी जो इंडियन भाषा है उनमें
एक्जेक्टली सेम होता है अगर आप बोलोगे तो
आप यह द मुझे जवाब दो या मुझे यह पसंद है
हमने बोलते मैं पसंद है मुझे पसंद है तो
यह डाट यूं करना हमारी भाषाओं में आलरेडी
है वैसे ही जब हमको बोलना है कि जर्मन महल
पन हेल्पलाइन जर्मन में डाकू है इस हेल्प
फल डियर शैंपू डर क्यों होता है क्या कर
रहे हो तुम तुम मदद कर रहे हो रही इसकी कर
रहा हूं यदि यह इसी लिए इस हेल्प फॉर डियर
या
कि मुझे जवाब दो जिसे मुखवास होता है जवां
कि से देते हुए मुझे इसलिए अनवांटेड में
भी डाउट यू ऑल द बेस्ट स्टूडेंट एंड
वोल्टेज डेमलर अगर डाट यू हुआ था क्योंकि
अट व्हाट डू है वैसे ही मुझे कुछ अच्छा
लगता है मैं कुछ अच्छा लगता है नहीं मुझे
कोई चीज अच्छी लगी मुझे यह कार अच्छी लगती
है तो क्या वह क्या डालूं टोंग यह फील्ड
नियर समझिए तुमने देखा देखा हेल्प हम देखा
यह फाइल देख और अंडरवर्ल्ड अनदेखा जो
हमारे हिंदी के जैसे यह है कि बटन अब एक
चीज और जैसे मैंने पहले भी पोलिथीन
कंसेप्ट सेवर है इसका मतलब यह नहीं कि जो
हर वर्ग जर्मन का डाट यह है वह हिंदी पर
भी डर्टी व्होर जो हिंदी का हर बार भाटी
वह जर्मन में भी ड्राफ्टिंग कंसेप्ट समझ
लो तो मैं और थोड़े व हम देखते हैं कि
जर्मन में डॉट होते हैं सबसे मोड
इंपोर्टेंट है इस डार्क पिन इन सब आपके
लिए हम जी का सिमरन करते
है इधर किसी को थैंक यू बोल रहा हूं तो आप
जब राइट इस डाकघर इन थे डाइजेस्टिव सिस्टम
कटर भी बोल सकते हो ओके वैसे ही तुम्हारा
कोंग्रेचुलेशन को कांग्रेस वेट करना है इस
ग्राफ क्लियर दिया अ इस ग्राफ ट्विटर या
फिर एकदम इंपॉर्टेंट की डिलीवरी आई विल
गिव यू इस्लाम व यह इश्क लव ऊ व य अगर
आपको बोलना है कि यह कार मेरी इस कर
बिलोंग्स टू मी तो हम बोलोगे हम बोलेंगे
दाउद टो ग्य है ओर नियर दास आउट टो ग्य है
ओर नियर तो अभी तक हमने यह सात वर्ग देखिए
ऐसे और कुछ वर्ड्स है fair लर्न पर्शियन
मगरे उनकी लिस्ट मैंने अभी आपको दी है जो
आपको दिख रही होगी आधार वर्ष देख सकते हो
कि वो सिंपल कंसेप्ट समझना इंपोर्टेंट है
कि वह अंदर बटन में देर क्यों आता है
डाकियों क्यों क्योंकि मुझे जवाब दो
कि एक पर को पता चल गया तो कुछ सिर्फ यह
याद रखना है कि यह जो सारे वर्ड्स है उनके
बर्थडे टीम लगाना है एकदम सिंपल है बट
एक्सेप्ट इन हमारी भारतीय भाषाओं जैसे ही
कंसेप्ट है यह तो आए हो आपको आज की कंडक्ट
समझ आई होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड
में धन्यवाद